[Music]
one of the concepts one of the
strategies that I'm most commonly asked
about from the 4-hour workweek is
batching there are many many many finer
points to this and quite aside from of
course 80/20 delegating outsourcing
Parkinson's law batching comes up again
and again and again so what is batching
to explain it in simplest terms we can
talk about laundry all right so you
wouldn't do your laundry every time you
have a new pair of dirty socks you wait
for a certain critical mass of dirty
laundry to accumulate and then you do
the laundry
why same with post office if you have
many different types of mail they're
going to come together that you need to
mail you're going to wait for a certain
critical mass as opposed to just going
there for every single letter because
there's a set-up cost there is a task
switching cost getting in the car
driving there spending the gas spending
the time laundry putting it all together
detergent and so on right so the the
time and labor involved in doing one
letter or twenty or one pair of socks or
entire basket of clothing is the same
and you want to be both effective and
efficient with your allocation of
resources ie time if you apply those to
business you can apply them in a million
and one different ways and I'll give you
a few examples one of the most common I
suppose directional questions or
specifics that I'm asked about is
frequency well do I batch on a daily
basis do I batch on a weekly basis do I
batch on a monthly or quarterly basis
and the answer is I do all of those
things but you don't have to try it all
at once I would not encourage you do
that I would encourage you to perhaps
try one or two approaches and see what
works for you this is a very personal
set of techniques you develop a
portfolio that works for yourself let me
tell you a few things that I and others
do for instance you might decide that on
a given day from the time you wake up
until lunch is your primary creation
period this could be writing it could be
recording it could be anything that is
proactively
creative and synthesis then once you
have lunch you are permitted to do
administrative tasks phone calls email
triage calendaring and so on I do this
quite a lot particularly from Tuesday to
Thursday on certain ways on a weekly
basis I know the CEO of a very
well-known startup pretty much everyone
watching this would know this company
and instead of batch on a daily basis
looking at his week Monday to Friday
he might have day one administrative
tasks day two HR hiring day three
product day for marketing and on each of
those days he will focus on thematically
or categorically those types of tasks
that is yet another approach and very
commonly I will batch phone calls on
Mondays and Fridays and in you know I
was saving broadly speaking this is
voice related tasks so I will have phone
calls and podcast recording on Mondays
and Fridays and this helps to prevent
also interruptions and task switching
that can result if you have
miscellaneous phone calls and podcasts
scattered throughout the week makes it
very difficult to do deep work on
anything that might require three to
five hours of uninterrupted time I am on
a quarterly basis you could look at
batch producing or completing certain
types of normally scattered activities
for instance I am recording this video
right now during a content generation
week where a week is blocked out once
per quarter to focus on answering common
questions that all of you or my readers
or listeners have asked and so on and so
forth on a say six month to a yearly
basis I have started in the last few
years batching travel why would I bet
travel in there many different reasons
to batch travel one of my reasons is
that I want to practice being off the
grid for extended periods of time to not
only remind myself and prove to myself
that it is possible to do that
no the internet will not stop the
universe will not end if you are
unavailable and unreachable for certain
periods of time and also to rejuvenate
to recharge being away from social media
and keyboards and laptop screens and so
on batching is one of the fundamental
concepts that you need to understand if
you understand the principle the reasons
for the concepts you can come up with
your own examples to experiment with and
these are not permanent changes think of
them as two-week experiments one tiny
thing that you can test with assuming
that it's on a daily or weekly basis and
try it out see what works keep what
works reject what doesn't add what is
uniquely your on borrowing from Bruce
Lee with that and before you know it you
will have a reliable dependable way of
making yourself more effective and more
efficient which is your bespoke
iteration of batching
you